XXX the return of xander cage that's
right the sequel to the best film ever
xxx
State of the Union starring Ice Cube not
Vin Diesel this one stars Vin Diesel
like the first one did back in 2002
which I think was everyone's favorite
action film of the year 2002 doesn't
matter it's the trilogy now and this
films directed by DJ Caruso who directed
2016's the disappointments room my
favorite movie of that year so I mean
this is bound to be great word so the
xxx program is basically a super-secret
organization of spies who are super
duper action heroes who also really
enjoy extreme sports and doing things
that don't make sense combined to film
extreme ops which also came out in 2002
with Die Another Day which also came out
in 2002 and you basically have xxx now
if you look at the specific blu-rays
that I have strategically placed in my
background that will tell you that I
really love dumb action movies I
actually have a major place in my heart
for a good old guilty pleasure action
film I mean look at this shit I hold in
my hand two VHS for die-hard - to tell
you everything you need to know about me
so part of me was actually really
excited to see this movie because I was
pretty sure it was going to be like that
unfortunately for me return of xander
cage this is the mark when it comes to
guilty pleasure action movie because at
too many times does this film take
itself seriously which is a major
mistake when you have people doing the
things that people do in this movie
which is everything from skateboarding
on the side of a bus jumping from one
skyscraper to another with literally
nothing assisting you other than the
momentum you got when you ran and of
course two people walking out into the
open when about 12 people are shooting
directly at you and you don't get hit
even once because it's really cool when
you move and you do things so that's the
level of guilty-pleasure action where
out here and that would be absolutely
fine with me if the film just maintained
that tone but the film honestly does
take itself a little seriously sometimes
and I couldn't help but see all of the
incredibly tired attempts and restarting
a franchise and it's good to be back
just about every moment in this movie is
like hey let's do another one after this
will you guys like that I think you will
because you know I'm Vin Diesel and I
don't like to do the second movies in my
big franchises I just come back later to
rescue them from obscurity can we get
the rock in the fourth one please that
might help the ending of this film is
like hey let's do a sequel the title of
this movie is like hey let's restart a
franchise everything about this movie
isn't a movie it's just some world
building franchise attempt thing see for
me a guilty pleasure action movie has to
be one very specific thing and that's
not pretentious all of my favorite ones
aren't coming commando Broken Arrow
these are movies that just throw all
caution to the wind and they rarely ever
try to get serious this film is very
much so like look at me I'm so fucking
cool admire me look at my muscles after
the seventh or eighth scene of random
women fawning over Vin Diesel's body
I checked out by the time he gets to the
big Mission Control Room he's already
banged like eight women I'm not even
kidding
and the secretary comes up and is like
oh my God look at your muscles you're so
sexy oh I'm such a big fan of you can I
put this body armor on you and touch
your body if you think I'm exaggerating
I'm not like after a while or just like
this is too much this is just too much I
don't need to be reminded how awesome
Vin Diesel is in every scene I already
like him as an actor I found him and
suffer ibly annoying in this movie in
fact I found most of the characters
extremely annoying Xander cage this is
crazy
I was at Katella & Guns and Roses got
back together but this is way cooler
take your time I know mouth-to-mouth is
necessary
particularly that girl who was fawning
over Vin Diesel in that scene she is the
Jar Jar Binks of this movie she even has
a Jar Jar Binks moment where she's so
scared to touch a gun that she drops it
on the ground and the gun starts like
jumping around shooting all the bad guys
perfectly just like at the end of
Phantom Menace when Jar Jar takes out
the battle droids by accident I'm just
sitting there like what am i watching
right now let me tell you some of the
people in this movie and then you can
tell me who you think is the best part
of the film
we got Vin Diesel we got Toni Collette
we got samuel l.jackson we got Donnie
Yen yeah it's Donnie Yen obviously he
has the best action scenes in the movie
he's the most convincing in them he was
the most entertaining character in the
film as well
Vin Diesel stunt double was pretty good
other than that he basically stood
around punched some people and said a
lot of war minors now let's talk about
those one-liners Vin Diesel cannot
deliver a one-liner
I'm sorry I like him again I must
reiterate I really like Vin Diesel not
just as an actor but as a guy like he
seems like a really cool guy but he does
not have a comedic bone in his body and
I really think they needed a much
funnier actor for a role of this kind
everything in this movie is so look at
me we're so fucking cool let's do
another one that I just couldn't even
get into this film there are a few
interesting action scenes that I have
fun with mostly surrounding Donnie Yen
there's a very cool fight scene on a
plane with no gravity I really like that
sequence and there's an amazing
hilarious laughs out loud explosion shot
at the end that I thought was just
really awesome but besides that this
movie just didn't do it for me and I'm a
big fan of guilty-pleasure action movies
it shouldn't have taken itself as
seriously as it did sometimes but if
you're a fan of the other two like if
you actually like xxx state of the union
I guess you'll probably enjoy this one
I'm going to give xxx return of xander
cage so you guys know my promotion was
audible is still going on if you go to
audible.com slash Chris you can start a
free trial for 30 days and download a
free audio book they have so many
amazing titles on that website I
personally enjoyed the legacy Star Wars
novels they have them all available for
you it's a fantastic service a lot of
people have mentioned to me that they
are grateful that I'm doing this
promotion I've been doing it
over a year now and I really like to
thank audible for continuing to work
with me and you guys for checking out
that service again it's audible.com
slash crisp that's a free 30-day trial
hundreds of thousands of titles so many
ways to listen mp3 player iPhone
everywhere it's a fantastic tool thank
you once again to audible please do
check out audible.com slash Kris for
that free 30-day trial guys thank you so
much as always for watching I hope you
enjoyed this review I'll be back very
soon with a spoiler review of split
because I did my review for that like
back in November and I'm excited to
finally talk about that ending I have
been waiting for a long time to do that
it has been hard
oh look forward that this weekend guys
did the best thinking once again if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck my knife
[Applause]
you
[Music]